[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
hallo Leute hier ist Toni und hier ist
Mirko hi den heutigen Fall beginnen wir
mit einem Facebook-Eintrag am 22 februar
2014 postete jemand in der Gruppe
vermisste Personen und Kinder folgende
Meldung der Polizei Wiesbaden
Schlangenbad Suche nach Britta B seit
Dienstag 18 februar wird die 37-Jährige
aus dem Schlangenbader Ortsteil Wambach
vermisst der Ehemann hatte letztmalig am
Dienstag gegen 13 Uhr per Mail Kontakt
zu seiner Frau und deren Aufenthaltsort
derzeit unbekannt ist der Ehemann hielt
sich zu diesem Zeitpunkt geschäftlich im
Ausland auf über der Meldung ist ein
Foto von Britta sie steht auf einem
Balkon oder einer Terrasse und schaut
ein bisschen angestrengt nach links in
die Kamera sie hat blondes Haar das in
Locken bis auf die Schultern fällt und
dunkle Augen die etwas ernster gucken
als es das Lächeln ihr kommundes
vielleicht jetzt erstmal vermuten lässt
und der Text geht weiter als der Mann am
Donnerstag nach Hause zurückkam traf er
laut Polizei seine Ehefrau dort nicht an
bei der Erstattung der Vermisstenanzeige
konnte er keine Angaben zum jetzigen
Aufenthaltsort seiner Ehefrau machen
aufgrund fehlender
Bekleidungsgegenstände wie zum Beispiel
Wanderschuhe und ähnliches geht der
Ehemann davon aus dass ihr
möglicherweise bei einem Spaziergang
etwas zugestoßen ist Zitat Ende das
einzige was an all dem stimmt ist Britta
B ist etwas zu gestoßen wir diskutieren
hier nämlich heute einen Fall der uns so
beschäftigt weil er als Mord ohne Leiche
schlagt sein machte um ihn zu verstehen
müssen wir das Paar besser kennenlernen
also Emanuel und Britta B Mirko
Emanuel B betreibt eine erfolgreiche
Unternehmensberatung zum privaten Glück
fehlt aber noch eine Partnerin
die findet er 2003 über ein Dating
Portal sie heißt Britta ist äußerlich
sehr attraktiv und arbeitet bei einer
Fluggesellschaft schon wenige Monate
später ziehen die beiden zusammen und
heiraten auch bald es zeigt sich das
Britta manchmal unter Angstattacken
leidet sie gibt ihren Job auf das Paar
beginnt den Bau einer Villa zu planen
wir schreiben jetzt das Jahr 2009 und
befinden uns im Schlangenbader Ortsteil
Wambach für die die sich da nicht so gut
auskennen das ist etwa 10 km westlich
von der Wiesbadener Innenstadt hier
steht für das kinderlose Paar bald eine
beeindruckende luxushütte von der alle
Nachbarn Staunen sprechen die helle
Villa mit viel Glas und einem schlechten
grauen Dach liegt auf einem 2500
Quadratmeter Grundstück und ist von
einem prächtig bepflanzten Garten
umgeben Haus und Hof machen viel Arbeit
Britta und Emanuel Leben eigentlich nur
noch für das Haus und in dem Haus
sie vernachlässigen Kontakte und fahren
kaum noch in den Urlaub wie Immanuel
später berichtet ist seine Frau nie
zufrieden wenn etwas in der Villa fertig
ist entscheidet sie sich um und lässt es
dann neu machen gleichzeitig sollen ihre
Panikattacken in dieser Zeit auch noch
schlimmer geworden sein nach außen
bringt von all dem nichts Immanuel
betreibt seine Firma aus dem Homeoffice
für die wenigen Besuche herrscht der
schöne Schein über diese Jahre sagt
immer Manuel später wir wollten richtig
toll Urlaub machen wenn das Haus endlich
fertig ist und wieder Freunde finden und
ein neues Leben anfangen aber immer wenn
Land in Sicht scheint zettelt Britta den
nächsten Umbau an eines Tages kommt dann
tatsächlich ein radikaler Wechsel aber
ganz anders als gedacht im Februar 2014
meldet Emanuel seine Frau bei der
Polizei vermisst und zwar so er sei von
einer Geschäftsreise aus Frankreich
zurückgekommen und habe Britta nicht zu
Hause angetroffen offenbar habe sie
Wandersachen mitgenommen denn ihre
Outdoorjacke und die Trekkingschuhe sein
ebenfalls weg die Polizei steht bei den
Ermittlungen nun vor unzähligen
möglichen Szenarien vielleicht hatte
Britta B beim Spazierengehen einen
Unfall oder jemand hat ihren
benachbarten Wald etwas angetan oder sie
ist aus freien Stücken fortgegangen um
ihren Mann zu verlassen fest steht von
ihr fehlt auch nach gründlicher Suche
mit Polizeihundertschaften und Hunden
jede Spur also wenden sich der dem Fall
zugeteilte Kommissar Stefan lange und
seine Kollegen dem Paar selbst zu und da
wird es zum ersten mal spannend ihn
fällt auf dass der Eingang der Villa von
einer Überwachungskamera gefilmt wird
sie sagten die Gerätschaften ein um sie
auf dem Präsidium dann zu untersuchen
und im kriminaltechnischen Labor stellt
sich heraus jemand hat die Kamera und
ihre Aufzeichnungen unbrauchbar gemacht
und jetzt wird die Polizei misstrauisch
sie untersucht alle Rechner und Geräte
des Paares der sie habhaft wird und so
enthüllen die datenexperten der Kripo
zwei Umstände
erstens Emanuel hat sich auf Brittas
Rechner einen eigenen Account
eingerichtet und von dem aus
fake-unterhaltungen mit seiner Frau
geführt und zweitens er hat in den
letzten Monaten massiv Kontakt zu
anderen Frauen gesucht jetzt nähert sich
der Fall einer dramatischen Zuspitzung
als die Beamten zur Villa fahren um B
zur Rede zu stellen hat der sich gerade
die Pulsadern aufgeschnitten der Mann
ist völlig von der Rolle Immanuel wird
in der Psychiatrie untergebracht und er
will plötzlich mit der Polizei reden er
tischt jetzt eine schräge Geschichte auf
und die geht so er und Britta hätten die
Schwiegereltern besucht und sein dann am
Rhein spazieren gegangen und da in einem
Moment habe er in die eine Richtung
geguckt und Britta in die andere
schließlich hörte er ein Platz und seine
Frau sei im Wasser gewesen und
fortgespült worden das überzeugt die
Kripo überhaupt nicht Emanuel B wird
festgenommen aber die wenigen Spuren wie
die kaputte Überwachungskamera erreichen
dem Landgericht Wiesbaden nicht aus um
ein Verfahren anzustellen im Gegenteil
Emmanuel B muss umgehend aus der U-Haft
entlassen werden es folgt ein Tauziehen
um den juristischen Fortgang wen nutzt
diese Zeit verkauft die Villa und zieht
nach Belgien aber zum Glück lässt die
Staatsanwaltschaft nicht locker und geht
in die Berufung im zweiten Anlauf lässt
das Landgericht eine Klage zu nur so ein
Fall ohne Leiche bleibt halt einfach
eine Zehe Geschichte für die Justiz
in einem ersten Verfahren reichen die
Beweise nicht aus erst als die Technik
hilft gibt es endlich Fortschritte die
zerstörten Dateien der
Überwachungskamera werden nochmal
bearbeitet und siehe da es lassen sich
aufnahmen wieder herstellen und vor
allem auch zeitlich sortieren und so
stellen die Beamten fest dass Britta B
noch am Abend ihres angeblichen
Verschwindens den Müll rausgebracht hat
danach aber nie wieder in Erscheinung
trat also ist auch entscheidend was die
Kamera nicht Film konnte nämlich eine
Britta in Wanderjacke und
trekkingschuhen auf dem Weg zu einem
Spaziergang dafür ist zu sehen wie immer
Manuel einige größere Gegenstände in die
Mülltonne gestopft hat boah das lässt
übles an und noch zwei weitere Spuren
verstärken den Schwung in den
Ermittlungen an Bees Auto findet sich
Brittas Blut außerdem hat er einen
sogenanntes Multitool gekauft mutmaßlich
um die Leiche seiner Frau zu zerlegen
ich muss kurz gestehen ich konnte mir
unter diesem Tool nichts vorstellen also
habe ich das mal gegoogelt hört mal wie
das in der Werbung klingt für Profis für
Heimwerker ein einziges Gerät für
sämtliche Arbeiten renovieren montieren
installieren ein Gerät das Ihnen
tausende von eurospart schneidet Holz
Kunststoff und Metall schleift mehr Geld
schafft frisst und schlitzt Problem
gelöst schneidet und schlitzt das ist
alles es ist ganz es ist ganz ganz
schlimm überhaupt gar keine schöne
Vorstellung was da abgegangen sein muss
an Emanuels Multitool findet man Blut
und gewebespuren die sich eindeutig
seiner Frau zuordnen lassen insgesamt
gibt es jetzt so viele Indizien und
Spuren das ist endlich zum Prozess kommt
das Verfahren beginnt im Sommer 2015 und
zieht sich über neun Monate hin am Tag
des Urteils im April 2016 schreibt Bild
das Landgericht sieht es als erwiesen an
dass der reiche Unternehmer Emmanuel B
seine Frau Britta 37 tötete die Leiche
dann mit einem Multifunktionswerkzeug
zerstückelte und beseitigte
Britta B starb demnach zwischen dem 16
februar 2014 in der Zeit zwischen 21 und
14 und dem frühen Morgen des 18 februar
eine Überwachungskamera an der feudalen
Villa des Paares lieferte das letzte
lebendbild der Frau die Villa wo
letztendlich der Grund für die Tat beide
Eheleute waren sehr penibel wollten das
perfekte Leben im Luxus Britta B suchte
sich immer neue Verbesserungsprojekte da
ihr das Millionen teurer Anwesen in
Schlangenbad Wambach offensichtlich nie
ideal genug war schließlich lebten die
beiden praktisch nur noch für das Haus
soziale Kontakte nahezu 0 auch die
vorher geliebten Reisen fanden nicht
mehr statt aber wie konnte Emanuel B in
diesem mörderische Lage kommen den
Prozess selbst hatte geschwiegen aber er
ließ sich von einer psy elektrischen
Gutachterin befragen und die beschreibt
ihn als ehrgeizig taff und auch als
arrogant einzig im Umgang mit Britta
soll er empathisch gewesen sein und so
machte er wohl auch jahrelang mit als
sie sich in den einrichtungswahn
hinsichtlich der Villa hineinsteigerte
aber irgendwann konnte er nicht mehr
okay ganz ehrlich dann hätte er sich
aber auch scheiden lassen können also
ich meine wenn jeder seine
Beziehungskrisen mit einem Mord löst
dann werden wir ja bald schon ein paar
Millionen weniger hast auf jeden Fall
einen wichtigen Punkt getroffen da
Emanuel im Prozess geschwiegen hat gibt
es dazu auch keine Aussage es darf aber
gemutmaßt werden dass er sich eine teure
Scheidung und die Aufteilung des
Vermögens ersparen wollte es wurde
ebenfalls gemunkelt Britta habe dunkle
Firmengeheimnis ihres Mannes gekannt das
würde zumindest einiges erklären was
mich auch ziemlich beschäftigt
welchen Anteil an all diesen Unglück an
dieser Tragik hat bitte diese fucking
Villa ich meine hier das war das Zitat
im bildartikel der Vorsitzende Richter
Jürgen Bongs sagte das Haus war das
zerstörerische Geschwür des irrlebens
also wäre ohne die Villa alles gut
gelaufen glaube ich eher nicht und ich
muss auch sagen diese Aussage er will
sich vermutlich die Scheidung sparen das
finde ich schon wieder so krass aber
passt vielleicht zu seiner Arroganz dass
dein eigener Vorteil dir wichtiger ist
als ein Menschenleben aber würdest du
dafür töten
das ist eine schwierige Frage
mir kam beim Lesen des Falls noch der
Gedanke dass die ständigen Umbauarbeiten
und diese ständige Hin und Her dass sie
da fabriziert hat beim Bau und Umbau
dieser Villa vielleicht so ein bisschen
dazu
gedacht waren um ihre psychischen
Probleme zu kompensieren das hat
natürlich immer nur kurzzeitig geklappt
sich damit abzulenken von den
eigentlichen Problemen die sie hat
wahrscheinlich wäre es wichtig gewesen
wenn sie sich im psychiatrische
Behandlung begeben hätte um ihre
Panikattacken und ihre anderen
psychischen Probleme in den Griff zu
bekommen das kann ja durchaus in so
einer Beziehung auch für ziemlich viel
Zündstoff sorgen na ja ich denke
allgemein so eine so eine paar Therapie
hätte Bein vielleicht ganz gut getan
weil ich meine Emanuel hat ja im
Endeffekt das Verhalten von Britta die
ganze Zeit runtergeschluckt bis er dann
halt irgendwann explodiert ist das
möchte ich ich möchte den da gar nicht
in Schutz nehmen sondern eher ihm auch
den Spiegel verhalten um zu sagen hey
junge also ich finde als Erwachsener
muss man ja auch die Größe haben sich
einzugestehen wir haben ein Problem und
ich bin für meine Frau da und
unterstützt sie dann gehen wir halt
vielleicht zusammen zur Therapie auch
wenn sie nicht angenehm ist wenn beide
das wollen ist das sicherlich eine
Möglichkeit da wir nicht genau wissen
wie er seine Frau getötet hat kann man
natürlich auch nicht genau
nachvollziehen wie explosiv die Stimmung
in der Beziehung gewesen ist und wie die
Tat halt dann letztlich zustande
gekommen ist ob es eine impulsivhandlung
war aus einem heftigen Streit heraus
oder ob er das geplant hatte ja ähm wo
bei sich quasi dann dieser Fall mit
vielen anderen Fällen die wir bisher
schon besprochen haben wahrscheinlich
wieder decken würde oder kreuzen oder
parallelen hätte ja und ähm ja bestimmt
und ich finde auch sehr faszinierend an
diesem Fall er hat ja geschwiegen im
Prozess ähm wie wichtig aber dann doch
die Spurensicherung ist und auch dieses
ständige checken was für neue
Möglichkeiten hat die Technik also muss
ich sagen da hat die Polizei schon eine
gute Arbeit geleistet noch mal über
diese
Überwachungskamera Tapes drüber zu gehen
weil ich meine letztendlich konnten sie
ja dadurch einzelne Sequenzen wieder
rekonstruieren und auch nachweisen dass
das was Immanuel der erzählt hat gar
nicht stimmen kann
abgesehen davon ist es natürlich auch
extrem auffällig wenn du selber
Überwachungskameras installiert hast und
ausgerechnet für den wichtigen Zeitraum
ja wie aus dem schlechten Film die
Bänder bzw die Aufnahmen für den
Zeitraum der wichtig ist fehlt das macht
natürlich sollte ihm ja auch klar sein
dass das jeden Beamten sofort stutzig
machen würde und dass man dann natürlich
wenn ein Verdacht besteht auch mehr ins
Detail geht und alles versucht um diese
Bänder bzw die Aufnahmen die Daten
wieder zu rekonstrieren dass er die mir
eigentlich klar sein müssen ja gut aber
äh ich möchte mir nicht anmaßen über
seine
Intelligenz zu urteilen aber besonders
clever hat er sich ja nicht angestellt
ich meine auch diese Story vom spazieren
gehen und dann guckt er einmal weg und
dann fällt seine Frau ins Wasser und ist
sofort weggespült ich weiß nicht ja das
klingt natürlich nach
notausrede nach einer Sache die er sich
nicht gut überlegt hat die sich schnell
zusammengestammelt hat offensichtlich
ich glaube abschließend kann man sagen
wirklich sehr sehr faszinierender Fall
diese Dynamik finde ich ultra
interessant das so augenscheinlich alles
an dieser blöden Villa gescheitert ist
natürlich steckt da noch viel viel mehr
dahinter aber wirklich ein sehr sehr
spannender Fall und ich muss auch sagen
extrem gute Polizeiarbeit dass sie da
auch rekonstruieren konnten dass er da
größere Gegenstände in die Mülltonnen
gestopft hat so schlimm das ist aber das
wird wahrscheinlich ja dann Britta sein
ich bin froh auf jeden Fall dass Sie
diese Dateien rekonstruieren konnten
weil überlegt man ansonsten Mord ohne
Leiche du hast keine keine Beweise
vielleicht wäre mit einem Freispruch
davon gekommen das hätte durchaus
passieren können denn man konnte sich ja
nur an Indizien festhalten und die waren
am Anfang ja sehr dürftig
man sieht das halt auch ganz
offensichtlich ein Leben in Wohlstand
keine Garantie für ein glückliches und
erfülltes eh Leben darstellen definitiv
mal kommt dass du mich dazu das war's
für heute wir haben euch den Fall mit
Artikeln aus der Bild-Zeitung erzählt
sowie in der FAZ und dem Spiegel und der
Chronik in der zdf-doku-reihe wahre
Verbrechen Skript Stefan Netzeband
Aufnahme und schnitt Toni Hayer
Postproduktion durch die weight watch
Studios München wir danken euch fürs
zuhören und seid auch beim nächsten Mal
wieder dabei euer Mirko und eure Toni